today's sponsor is blue Chu and they're
giving you your first shipment totally
free all you have to do is pay five
dollars for shipping go to blue chewed
comm use promo code David I've put the
link right underneath this video I have
a ton of non Trump news to discuss with
you today and in a moment we're gonna be
focusing in on Arizona and the Senate
race that's going on in Arizona but
before I do that I want to talk about
the Senate more broadly a little bit I
don't know with everything that's going
on how many people in my audience are
following what's going on with the
Senate for November of 2020 but it is
increasingly clear that if we all come
together if we do the hard work if we do
the phone banking if we get out there
and vote there is a realistic shot that
Republicans could lose control of the
Senate in November now a year ago when
we were talking about this I was mostly
saying it's like a 5% chance I mean
Democrats couldn't take the Senate but
really we're probably going to have to
wait until 2022 to see Republicans lose
control of the Senate and then six
months ago things have shifted a little
bit I did a segment pointing out it's in
play it's probably still like a 20% shot
at taking the Senate for Democrats
there is now an increasingly realistic
scenario where Democrats snatched
control of the Senate from Republicans
in November now to refresh the numbers
right now the balance of power is 53 to
47 in favor of Republicans that is the
47 is 45 Democrats and then two
independents Bernie Sanders and angus
King that's how you get to 47 if the
Senate is tied 50/50 the vice president
gets to cast the tie-breaking vote so
right now if Democrats want control they
need a net gain of four seats or three
seats plus the presidency because then
Joe Biden's vice president becomes the
tiebreaker in a 50/50 Senate now
Democrats are going to lose Alabama this
is just a reality Alabama there's the
Senate seat that used to be Jeff
Sessions seat Republican jeff sessions
became trump's beleaguered Attorney
General Doug Jones defeated serial
accused sex assault or Roy
more but that is anomaly an anomaly
depending on how you like to pronounce
it and Jeff Sessions is running for that
seat again and he's almost certain to
win he's winning by a ton so in practice
losing that one this means Democrats
need five wins against Republicans or 4
wins plus the presidency and it is not a
crazy scenario at this point to imagine
that that might happen it would be a
major turn of events from what we would
have been looking at six months ago in
great part you would blame Trump you
could blame the virus but Republicans
have a very difficult path now to
defending control of the Senate compared
to 6 or 12 months ago you've got a
hundred senators they served six-year
terms that means every two years a third
of the Senate is up for re-election
right now we have 33 races plus two
special elections Arizona and Georgia
and of those 35 Republicans have to
defend 23 whereas Democrats are only
defending 12 in other words Republicans
have 23 seats they could lose whereas
Democrats have only 12 seats that they
could lose now I've already mentioned
Alabama and Democrats almost certainly
Democrats are going to lose that Alabama
Senate seat let's look at the best shots
for Democrats to take seats from
Republicans first of all you've got
Colorado where John Hickenlooper the
Democrat is leading the incumbent
Republican Cory Gardner by 13 that will
very likely flip in Arizona Mark Kelly
is leading martha mcsalley the incumbent
Republican by an average of nine now in
one recent poll it's 13 and we'll talk
about that a little later in Maine you
have Sarah Gideon the Democratic
challenger to longtime Republican
senator Susan Collins ahead by about two
and a half and then in North Carolina
it's very close Cal Cunningham the
Democratic challenger ahead of incumbent
Republican senator Thom Tillis
by one I mean that that's like a tie
it's the margin of error then you've got
some longer shots for Democrats in terms
of the longer shots in Montana Steve
Bullock has a very good recent poll
against the incumbent Republican Steve
Daines
I'm still calling it a long shot because
it is
just one poll and it is Montana but
Montana doesn't look bad for Democrats
then you've got Georgia Kansas and Iowa
which are as we're calling them those
are long shots for Democrats but they
are not completely impossible so the
news is the Senate is very much in play
it's very much worth fighting for this
has been a big reversal over the last
six and particularly if you look at what
the polling was twelve months ago but
voters need to vote otherwise this is
nothing this is going to be another
opportunity lost if people don't get out
and vote I don't want to see that happen
now let's focus in on one Senate race
and I'll use it to look more broadly at
the signal that the Senate races could
send about the presidential race let's
dig into Arizona right now
okay so Arizona is a very interesting
state since the passing of the late john
mccain martha mcsalley
was appointed as senator there she has
never won a campaign but she's running
to keep her seat in November she's
running against or running against her I
think is better
the right way to say it his Democratic
challenger Mark Kelly Mark Kelly is a
former astronaut twin brother of Scott
Kelly who's been a guest on this program
in a new poll out of Arizona Mark Kelly
is ahead of martha mcsalley by 13 points
on an average in recent polling mark
kelly is ahead by nine points now let's
look at prior results in Arizona in 2012
Republican Jeff Flake defeated the
Democratic challenger Richard Carmona
by 3 in 2016 John McCain won in Arizona
by 13 although admittedly that the
numbers are complicated by the fact that
there was a three-way race the Green
Party candidate got about 6% and
presumably most of that 6% came from the
Democratic candidate so McCain won by 13
could have been more like 7 had there
been no Green Party candidate right now
the Republican incumbent in Arizona is
down by 13 to Mark Kelly so what's
interesting is to look not just at the
Senate numbers in Arizona but also look
at the presidential numbers in the same
poll where Martha McSally is down 13 to
Kelly Joe Biden is ahead of Donald Trump
by seven in Arizona 52:43 now we want to
be careful with these numbers 50 plus 43
is 93 that leaves seven percent either
undecided or third-party a lot of that
7% could break for Trump and then you
would have a real race in Arizona but it
could also reverse right if the economy
does not improve if the corona virus
continues to run rampant it could go
more in Biden's favor at the same time
if November sees us with a lull in
coronavirus maybe between waves 1 & 2 or
with an economy that is looking better
it could end up looking far better for
Donald Trump these are just bad numbers
for Trump and Martha McSally today in
2016
Trump won Arizona by about three and a
half so Biden plus 7 is a 10-point swing
in the other direction now why do we
care so much about Arizona Arizona
you know that's relatively small state
it's only 11 electoral votes why does
Arizona matter so much what you have to
understand is that elections rarely go
as 50 completely isolated elections
where what happens in Arizona has
nothing to do with what happens in
Wisconsin or in Michigan for example if
you see a big reversal in one place
often there will be a number of other
places where you will see a move in the
same direction when you look at Trump's
path to victory all paths to victory
reasonably assumed that he has to hold
Arizona and probably he has to hold
Florida Florida's a very big question
mark for Donald Trump right now
particularly with older voters getting
away from Trump and going in the
direction of Joe Biden if Trump doesn't
get Florida Arizona is essentially a
must-win and in just about every
scenario Arizona becomes a must-win in
addition to Wisconsin Michigan
Pennsylvania North Carolina Trump can
win 270 electoral votes without Arizona
but it's really really tough and if
Trump does lose Arizona you have to
imagine it's not just that he loses
Arizona he probably loses something else
from 20
sixteen as well this is why looking at
the Senate race matters so much
Biden plus seven over Trump maybe you
believe it maybe you don't Mark Kelly
plus 13 over incumbent Republican
senator martha mcsalley even if the lead
is only half of that a Democratic
challenger knocking out an incumbent
Republican senator in Arizona by six or
seven which is half of what this last
poll says that does not bode well for
Republicans in general and it would not
bode well for Donald Trump in Arizona as
well really interesting race to look at
and we're going to follow it in 2018 six
out of ten federal offices in Arizona
went to Democrats that could be the
turning point year in Arizona for the
red-blue balance in that state and of
course Mark Kelly is no progressive hero
but he is so much better than martha
mcsalley and it would be a big win in
terms of just their politics as well
monday is Memorial Day it's the first
day off for the David Pakman show
outside of weekends in four or five
months we've been going hard with
coronavirus we're just at home so we've
just been working every day we are going
to be taking the day off but running a
huge membership special one-day
membership special if you've been
thinking about supporting the work we do
but the pricing has been dissuading you
Monday we will email everybody on our
mailing lists on our newsletter with a
huge membership discount code very easy
to get on the mailing list just go to
david pakman.com upper right of the
website type in your email address
Monday you will be notified about that
we'll take a quick break and be back
right after this the david pakman show
at david pakman.com
[Music]
this episode was sponsored by blue Chu
giving my viewers their first shipment
totally free when you go to blue to calm
and use promo code David it's just a
reality that many men regardless of age
can sometimes benefit from a boost in
confidence a little bit of performance
help blue chew is the first chewable
tablet with the same fda-approved
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis blue to
being a chewable tablet means it starts
working twice as fast as a pill it's
prescribed online you spend a couple
minutes with a short questionnaire a
licensed doctor reviews the information
decides if a prescription is right for
you it's then shipped directly to your
home in discreet packaging no awkward
visits to the doctor's office or
pharmacy plus it's also cheaper than
getting it at a pharmacy when you go to
blue to calm and use promo code David
you will get your first shipment
completely free just pay $5 shipping
that's promo code David you get your
first shipment of blue two completely
free and I've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are Robert Reese and Julia Wilson
Robert and Yulia thank you so much for
your support and also a huge thank you
to David Bevers Dorf who's been a member
for almost five years and is today's
longtime sustaining member of the day
grab a membership and get all the
benefits instantly plus that really
great feeling that you're supporting
something better than the news channels
you get through your cable subscription
something you actually may be choosing
to support grab a membership at join
pakman.com takes under a minute and you
will be pleased that you did that I can
promise you okay so we've been talking
about with the virus should we be voting
by mail in November and Donald Trump has
insisted that vote by mail leads to
voter fraud despite the fact that he
votes by mail we've talked about really
it's the swing states the battlegrounds
that are most important to ensure we can
vote by mail so that we don't hold down
Democratic turnout in a vote by mail or
not California's going to Joe Biden vote
by mail or not Massachusetts is going to
Joe Biden but it's those key swing
states and even some battleground or
purplish red states where it's really
important that voting by mail be done we
know that higher turnout is bad for
Republicans and we have really really
good news Texas federal judge has ruled
yesterday that anyone who doesn't want
to go out and vote in person in Texas
because they are afraid of catching
coronavirus is entitled to get an
absentee ballot now this is not as good
as vote by mail by default and I'll
explain to you why the best scenario
would be the state says every registered
voter is going to get an absentee ballot
in the mail whether they request one or
not this is not that you do have to
request an absentee ballot but in normal
circumstances in Texas you have to
justify why are you asking for an
absentee ballot you have to meet certain
criteria and it would be a fight over
does fear of catching the virus
qualified qualify you for an absentee
ballot we've now heard from District
Judge Fred berry and judge Fred berry
says the disability provision
applies to any voter who does not have
immunity to coronavirus and fears they
would catch it at a polling place this
is a very technical ruling Texas has
this Election Code which defines a
disability as a sickness or physical
condition that prevents the voter from
appearing at the polling place on
Election Day without a likelihood of
needing personal assistance or of
injuring the voters health the court
said fear and anxiety is inextricably
intertwined with voters physical health
and if you are apprehensive about going
to the vote to going to the in-person
ballot box and catching coronavirus that
is a limit on your ability to cast the
ballot so the court decided lack of
immunity to the kuraki
to the coronavirus counts as a physical
condition you would be entitled to
request an absentee ballot under that
pretense now there's a few caveats here
um you will be able to do this request
an absentee ballot merely for fear of
catching coronavirus until this decision
goes to trial or the pandemic goes away
so I don't know how you define the
pandemic has gone away in November if
there are fewer cases if there are fewer
deaths would that potentially be seen as
there is no more pandemic and voters
will not be allowed to vote for
president by mail right now this will
apply to the July elections in Texas for
example July 14th there's a primary
runoff in Texas anybody who is afraid of
catching coronavirus will be able to
request an absentee ballot November is
still more of a question mark and of
course Republicans don't like it they're
going to fight to have this cancelled by
the time of the presidential election
you've got the Texas Attorney General
Ken Paxton who says that this could be
something that opens the door to fraud
and this is the talking point that the
right is choosing to die on essentially
it's the Hildur choosing to die on
voting by mail should be available to
anybody who wants it period the entire
state of Oregon has had vote by mail for
20 years more than 20 years they've put
it in place in 1998 they had a ballot
initiative it passed about 70 to 30 and
it's funny how you look at the arguments
in 1998 against about 97 90
against vote-by-mail in Oregon and it's
the exact same thing that Republicans
are saying right now you go back and
look at the comments in the 90s in
Oregon from people like state Rep Lynn
Snodgrass or anti-tax activist bill
Sizemore in the 90s they were saying we
can't have vote-by-mail in Oregon it'll
invite election fraud it'll allow people
to pressure others about how they vote
now the truth is vote-by-mail is very
popular in oregon eighty-one percent
support in 2003 really hard to get
eighty percent support for anything
right now but more importantly thirty
percent of respondents in Oregon in 2003
said they vote more often since
vote-by-mail wasn't active enacted that
is what Republicans don't want that is
what scares the hell out of Trump about
vote-by-mail for November of 2020 let's
put vote-by-mail in place in more places
and let's also understand that we should
really focus in on the swing states now
on the fraud question vote-by-mail does
not lead to more fraud check out the
numbers that we have over the last
twenty years two hundred and fifty
million votes have been cast by mail
nationally twelve hundred cases of voter
fraud in all forms have been identified
eleven hundred resulting in criminal
convictions so what do we know over the
last twenty years we have had almost no
actual voter fraud it almost always
eleven hundred out of 1200 times it led
to a criminal conviction meaning you are
very likely to get punished and be found
guilty if you participate in voter fraud
and when you look at how many of those
were with absentee ballots it's only 200
of the 1,200 okay so of the almost
non-existent voter fraud 1200 cases
one-sixth were with absentee ballots
that means seven or eight cases per year
nationally okay seven or eight not seven
or eight percent not 0.7 or 0.8% seven
or eight cases nationally per year of
absentee ballot related voter fraud
which is
only one sixth of the total most of them
are in person no methodology is perfect
fraud is not an issue with vote-by-mail
do not let them trick you make them
provide the evidence of it because there
is no evidence the numbers are
overwhelming I have to apologize to you
today I made a mistake on a story I got
a story wrong and I want to fix it today
Donald Trump has been floating the idea
of cutting the employee side of the
payroll tax for the rest of the year as
a way to get more money in people's
pockets people earning under one hundred
and thirty eight thousand dollars per
year I have multiple times said I was
supportive of this idea because it is
true that it would in the immediate put
money back in the pockets of workers
earning under a hundred and thirty eight
thousand dollars a year but I was wrong
to support it I was wrong and I'm going
to explain why today now for people who
don't know why or what the payroll tax
is if you are a normal w-2 employee
you're not a you don't work for yourself
you're not a small business owner you
just work somewhere like most people do
you and your employer share some taxes
that come off of your payroll up until
you earn one hundred and thirty seven
thousand seven hundred dollars per year
once you get to 137 seven per year you
no longer pay these taxes there are two
taxes 12.4% towards Social Security and
2.9 percent for Medicare okay it only is
on the first hundred and thirty seven
point seven thousand dollars a year that
you earn that is a total twelve point
four and two point nine that's about
fifteen point three percent the worker
pays half and the employer pays half so
the fifteen point three percent is split
seven point six five percent for you
seven point six five percent for the
employer Trump's idea was let's suspend
the employee half seven point six five
percent through the end of the year but
you would have to pay for it when you
file your taxes in 2021 for this year so
it is not a cut it is a tax
holiday now initially I said listen I do
like it because it puts money directly
back in the hands of people earning
under a hundred and thirty eight
thousand dollars a year right now it is
not a tax cut for the rich and I thought
it was a good idea
I was wrong to support it for three
different reasons and most importantly
this is another way to actually back
handedly weaken Social Security and
Medicare and I want to go through each
of these reasons one by one so three
parts here number one the people who are
in the roughest shape right now are the
35-ish million people who lost their
jobs if you lost your job you're not
paying a payroll tax because you don't
have a job so seven point six five
percent tax holiday off the payroll tax
for people who aren't on any payroll is
not useful at all second the people who
do have jobs are mostly earning the same
amount of money now I'm not saying they
wouldn't love not to pay this seven
point six five percent but you've got
thirty five million people that
straight-up lost their jobs so to them
the payroll tax holiday doesn't make a
difference most people fortunately for
now are still working and have not seen
a decrease in pay some people are still
working but have seen a decrease in pay
but it is not that many people the bulk
of the workers right now have not seen a
decrease in pay or are completely
unemployed and thus unaffected by a
payroll tax holiday and then number
three it is only a tax holiday this is
not a tax cut if you earn a hundred
thousand dollars for example in a year
that means in the second half of the
year you would expect to earn about
fifty thousand dollars for now saving
seven point six five percent puts thirty
eight hundred dollars back in your
pocket but it is only a tax holiday when
you file your taxes in 2021 and you
punch in how much you've paid for Social
Security and Medicare TurboTax or
whatever your accountant whoever will
spit out hey
that thirty eight hundred dollars you
didn't pay in the second half of twenty
twenty you've got to pay it back in
right now because it was only a tax
holiday so doing this payroll tax cut
would target a relatively small group it
would deprive the government of
nine hundred and fifty billion dollars
in revenue through the end of the year
it would weaken Social Security and
Medicare which could then open the door
to dirty tricks from people like Trump
and Larry Kudlow and others to say hey
we got to do something with Social
Security and Medicare we don't have that
much money because of the tax holiday
you put in place and you've still got to
pay it back next year so we can't let
them do it I apologize that I was
supportive of this early on given
everything we now know I cannot in good
conscience support this and I'm sorry
that I suggested that it would have been
a good idea we're gonna continue
following this on Instagram our
instagram is david pakman show you can
also follow me on Instagram personally
at David Pakman we'll take a quick break
and be back right after this the david
pakman show at david pakman.com the
David Pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world's
famous bonus show as well as commercial
free audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at join
pakman.com coupon code saves you 40%
vote soon 18
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show so
last week I mentioned that I would be
significantly limiting my coverage of
the so-called Obama gate scandal because
floating these conspiracy theories is
how Donald Trump wins it's how Trump
distracts it's how Donald Trump creates
cover for himself and in this case
Donald Trump has failed on coronavirus
he's fired four inspectors general in
the last few months and the way Trump
distracts from this is to get media
debating Obama gate get media talking
about his supposedly taking
hydroxychloroquine so I'm going to do
this today because there's actually
something to tell you about which is a
leaked document that shows that Barack
Obama acted completely appropriately
back in 2016 and 2017 when it comes to
the Michael Flint investigation now I
also you know there's people in my
audience who may not even really know
what the Obama gate scandal supposedly
is Donald Trump clearly doesn't really
understand it he called it the greatest
political crime in the history of the
United States and yet when he was asked
for an explanation of what crime was
committed Trump didn't know where he
refused to say and he went on to attack
the journalists who asked the question
but generally and I don't want to spend
an hour on this because it's just not
worth it but we do have news today
generally Obama Gate is related to the
investigation into Donald Trump's
disgraced former national security
adviser Michael Flynn and Michael
Flynn's eventual guilty pleas on on
multiple counts the allegations
generally speaking of Obama Gate our
Obama acted inappropriately
he pushed law enforcement to do this or
that to Flynn Obama was the puppeteer of
a political hack job on Flynn in order
to attack Trump even to remove Trump and
it was all illegal despite the fact that
we still don't have clarity on what
crimes supposedly were even committed if
you really want to know more about the
details you can find them but it's just
not even worth explaining it to you we
now have a released unredacted memo from
Barack Obama's then National Security
Advisor Susan Rice this is what's called
a containment
contemporaneous memo it's dated Friday
January 20 2017 it's a summary of her
notes from the January 5th meeting that
is the center of a lot of this and again
I I sort of don't want to go deep on
this because it's a huge waste of time
but I want to get some of this on the
record for everybody in the letter in
the memo that Susan Rice wrote she says
there was a briefing from the
intelligence community about Russian
hacking during 2016 and after that
briefing there was a meeting which she
participated in the meeting involved
President Barack Obama then FBI director
James Comey Deputy Attorney General
Sally Yates Obama's national security
adviser Susan Rice who wrote this memo
and Vice President Joe Biden so good we
know who was there Susan Rice goes on to
say President Obama began the
conversation by stressing his continued
commitment to ensuring every aspect of
this issue is handled by the
intelligence and law enforcement
communities by the book okay the
president stressed he is not asking
about initiating or instructing anything
from a law enforcement perspective he
reiterated that our law enforcement team
needs to proceed as it normally would by
the book it goes on to say Obama wants
to ensure that in their interactions
with the incoming Trump administration
they know if there are reasons they
should not share information fully about
Russia James Comey then confirmed they
will go by the book and added that he
has some concerns that incoming national
security adviser Michael Flynn is
speaking more frequently than would be
normal or typical with Russian
ambassador Sergei kiss' lyac and it
could be an issue when it comes to
sensitive information Comey said
potentially the outgoing administration
the Obama administration should be
careful about passing sensitive
information related to Russia to Michael
Flynn because of the unusual level of
communication between Flynn and the
Russian ambassador it's there in black
and white Obama wanted nothing
special Comey had these concerns period
there is no crime there particularly on
the behalf of Barack Obama the only
shocking thing about this letter is how
a politically and professionally Barack
Obama handled this which I know seems
inconceivable in the era of Donald Trump
now there's a few other things to
mention Barack Obama warned Donald Trump
about Michael Flynn during the
transition period if Barack Obama were
involved in shady business why on earth
would he call attention to it by
mentioning Michael Flynn to Donald Trump
why go to Trump and say be careful with
Flynn if Obama is the one working on a
criminal trumped-up bogus hack job of
Michael Flynn it makes no sense now
lastly there are people arguing that the
proof that the FBI and trapped Michael
Flynn is there are notes from January
24th before a Michael Flynn
interrogation where they said one of the
goals of this interrogation is to get
Michael Flynn to lie and there are
people who are wildly saying that's
proof that it was a setup this is a
perjury trap this is entrapment I hate
to break it to you guys but this is
nothing controversial these are FBI
notes in advance of an interrogation
about their goals for the interrogation
it's done all the time Flynn had already
lied at that point and what they are
making reference to here is they want to
get Flynn's repeated lie on the record
this is not a perjury trap there is also
you know perjury trap has a very narrow
definition and it's when there is no
reason to suspect a crime has been
committed and you bring someone in for
an interview only to get them to lie
absent any information that they've
already lied in the past or have been
potentially involved in any other crime
999 out of a thousand times when the
term perjury trapped is perjury trap is
used it simply does not apply Michael
Flynn lied multiple times he pleaded
guilty to two counts he had denied that
he told kiss lyac to back off from
escalating the situation in response to
sanctions that was a lie he lied about a
follow-up phone call I think there was a
third matter Flynn lied about that I now
can't recall and given the number of
lies that Flynn told he actually got a
pretty damn good deal he's a retired US
general
he got money from at least one foreign
government Turkey he could have been
charged with conspiracy he could have
been charged with failure to register as
a foreign agent like his business
partner Rafiki and did and in the end he
actually got a pretty good deal
lastly if James Comey had it in for
Trump and wanted Hillary to win and this
Flynn thing was part of that
why did Comey not once but twice hold an
optional press conference to talk about
the investigation into Hillary Clinton's
emails not once but twice including
right before the November election it
makes no sense it is a really dumb way
for Comey to hurt Trump and help Hillary
to hold two press conferences or press
briefings public statements talking
about the investigation into Hillary
Clinton's emails so this entire Obama
Gate thing has backfired
it has spectacularly imploded and very
quickly you are starting to see the
people around Donald Trump move on to
new things and it is all to distract
from trump's horrifying pandemic
response this is how trump wins every
document that comes out shows that
Barack Obama certainly committed no
crimes it shows James Comey handled this
in a way that correspondent with how you
would have to sensitively deal with
something when you know you have an
incoming national security official that
has to be investigated it has evaporated
before our very eyes okay we have to
talk about yesterday's cabinet meeting
Donald Trump had a cabinet meeting in
front of the cameras yesterday the
president's cabinet is a very important
organization entity it's part of the
executive branch there are 23 members
plus the vice president 15 principal
officers 7 other members Trump is the
chairman of the cabinet the cabinet is a
really big deal and yesterday's cabinet
meeting was a veritable house of horrors
freak show and I would be doing
everybody a disservice if I pretended
that this didn't go down so this is
going to be a little painful but come
along with me we are going to spend some
time today going through some of what
took place yesterday
starting with what was a completely
insane moment Donald Trump was asked
given that minority communities are
disproportionately affected by
coronavirus
what specifically are you doing for them
Trump didn't answer and at one point
Trump essentially listed races and
ethnicities take a look at this
president you continue to talk about
helping minority communities what
specifically are you looking at to help
those communities what actions so one of
the things I was most proud of was the
minority community and all of the work
we've done for the minority communities
black unemployment Hispanic unemployment
Asian unemployment was the best ever in
the history of our country we've never
had anything like it we've never had so
many african-american jobs ever ever in
the history of our country by far and we
are bringing our country back and a big
focus is exactly that with the
minorities specifically if you look at
the Asians they've done incredibly well
Hispanics incredibly well
african-americans record-setting every
month you know that every month it was a
record-setting jobs number yes black
Hispanic Asian those certainly exist
that's true but it's not an answer and
by the end of this two-minute answer
which I'm not going to subject you to in
total Donald Trump was talking about
completely unrelated things like
ventilators at one point now people
often ask why don't the press call Trump
out and say you're not answering the
question you're not answering the
question the format makes it difficult
Trump will just move on to the next
person the microphone gets moved they'll
call the reporter following up you know
a nasty person or call it a nasty
question he actually does that a little
bit later today
and if you actually do get to press
Trump on a follow-up he'll just tell
three more lies and it genuinely is
pretty difficult now of course the topic
of hydroxychloroquine came up the day
before yesterday Donald Trump claimed
that he's been taking hydroxychloroquine
prophylactically for weeks and Donald
Trump claims that the best randomized
controlled trial that we have about
hydroxychloroquine is a fake false study
hydroxychloroquine should not use
outside of a hospital setting or no
that's not what I was though no there
was a false study done where they gave
it to very sick people extremely sick
people people that were ready to die it
was given by obviously not friends of
the administration and the study came
out the people were ready to die
everybody was old had bad problems with
hearts diabetes and everything else you
can imagine so they gave it so
immediately when it came out they gave a
lot of false information just so you
understand great studies came out of
Italy on hydroxy you know what I'm
talking about right right so it's true
it was given to people sick enough to
already be in the hospital that is true
but it was not a fake false study it was
a proper study it had a placebo group it
had randomization it's the best study we
have so far now let me go back to just
that last moment of trumps answer
briefly Trump does seem to forget what
the drug is called there he seems to
glitch he says hydroxy and then he has
this vacant look in his eyes he seems to
forget what he's talking about fumbles
to recover and asks the reporter if they
know what he's talking about take a look
at that moment again and just so you
understand great studies came out of
Italy on hydroxy you know what I'm
talking about right right great studies
came out really strange stuff for short
from falling apart completely now one
more glitch here Trump said something
about DOCSIS I I guess he was trying to
say doctor here ourselves many many
doctors doctors many doctors came out
and they said it's great now you have to
go to a doc okay so that one doesn't
need too much more discussion and then
lastly on hydroxychloroquine here is
Trump saying that hydroxychloroquine
doesn't harm anyone which is untrue
there are people who have been harmed by
taking this medication is true one way
or the other way that you like it or not
it's been around for 70 years
unbelievably effective for malaria and
for lupus and probably effective for
arthritis and what has been determined
is it doesn't harm you it's a very
powerful drug I guess but it doesn't
harm you and so I thought as a frontline
defense possibly it would be good and
I've had no impact from it I've had no I
feel the same I haven't changed I don't
think too much and at some point you
know I won't take it might be soon might
be a little bit it doesn't it doesn't
seem to have any impact on me but it
seems to be a extra line of defense and
it's gotten tremendous reviews from some
people he's not a different person as a
result of taking the drug that's good to
know now here's a really odd moment
Treasury secretary Stephen minuchin
announced they're going to be sending
out debit cards to people with stimulus
money instead of cheques or direct
deposits in some cases and he actually
takes out and presents a debit card to
Trump with Trump's name on it and he
seems to be explaining to Trump how
debit cards work which actually is not
super surprising a debit card looks like
with your name on it mr. president now
there's no money for you on it this is a
blank debit card but I want you to see
what many Americans will now get so that
we could get their money to them even
quicker and going forward we think
Tabard cards are a safe and secure way
of delivering refunds so I saw the
letter again Steve's had a great career
now it is quite possible that Donald
Trump doesn't not know how debit cards
work he's been a rich guy his whole life
he may not understand how a debit card
works but my question is whether this is
actually a good idea if you send someone
a debit card how do you pay rent with
that how do you pay your mortgage with
that you often can't pay those with a
debit card and when you do you sometimes
pay three four five even six percent in
fees so it seems like a strange idea to
me quite frankly we certainly need to
learn more about it and then here is
Donald Trump once again calling a female
reporter rude and telling her that's
enough of you when she tries to follow
up go ahead mr. president why haven't
you announced a plan to get 36
million unemployed Americans back to
work you're overseeing historic economic
despair we've announced a plan we're
opening up our country just a rude
person you are we're opening up our
country and we're opening it up very
fast
the plan is that each state is opening
and it's opening up very effectively and
when you see the numbers I think even
you will be impressed which is pretty
hard to impress you yeah go ahead and
then very last thing this is a bonus
from earlier in the day this was before
Trump's cabinet meeting Trump was asked
about Nancy Pelosi's comments about him
the day before that as a morbidly obese
man as she put it Donald Trump should
not be taking hydroxychloroquine and
here's how Trump reacted these people
are sick Pelosi is a sick woman she's
got a lot of problems a lot of mental
problems we're dealing with people that
have to get their act together for the
good of the country
okay so there it is a 73 year old rich
guy who literally wears orange clown
makeup says that Nancy Pelosi is the one
who is mentally sick so these events are
seen around the world the civilized
world can't believe that this is what's
happening here we are the laughingstock
and as I told you earlier this week we
are increasingly pitied by the world
because this is the guy who's running
the show people see this people see this
and even if a trumpet thinks this is
great what a great from taking
hydroxychloroquine and calling out
reporters her nasty questions and all of
this stuff the world sees it they laugh
and they pity us and it's a really major
embarrassment it's a national nightmare
that we'd really need to end that we
have the opportunity to
just over five months ago the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
Florida has fired the scientist who
created their coronavirus dashboard that
tracks most states have something like
this it tracks daily cases of deaths and
other data and it is alleged that she
has been fired because she was refusing
to manipulate or I would call it falsify
data for political reasons to make
reopening seem like a more reasonable
thing to do now this scientist name is
Rebecca Jones she put together these
dashboards so that you could go and see
in real time where are the outbreaks
were the cases and deaths she wasn't
paid for this additional work that she
did she did it over a two-month period
and it is claimed that she was told to
censor or manipulate some data and she
refused to do it she was told to
manually change some data to help build
the case that reopening makes sense and
she refused to do it as she says and she
has now been fired now the interesting
thing about this coming out of Florida
is that I guess it was almost two weeks
ago I think it was on them not the last
Friday show but the previous one or
maybe the one before that time is all
blending together we had reports from a
few weeks ago that Florida was already
being accused of being dishonest about
their deaths and they were fielding
cause of death from these reporting
agencies this if true is North Korea
style propaganda too many deaths and
cases to reopen just make up different
numbers no problem whatsoever and again
I think it's important to underscore
that a lot of the headlines say that she
was refusing to manipulate data
she was refusing to falsify data
selectively releasing data or changes or
the manipulation this is falsification
it would be a form of fraud or
straight-up lies they are doing what
Trump and Republicans have been accusing
China of doing they are doing what Trump
and Republicans have been said you know
maybe the death tolls are being
overstated well it looks like they are
being accused of doing the exact thing
although in the opposite direction to
make this seem less bad than it actually
is
of course there are always details that
are late coming in was she straight-up
fired or forced to resign it's not clear
she's not communicating very much
Rebecca Jones's with with reporters over
the last 12 to 16 hours
what exactly was she asked to change
we're not really sure yet what was
observed was that over the last couple
weeks the demographic info about who is
getting infected and dying has been more
difficult to access as one example
reporters have been having more and more
trouble finding out how many cases and
deaths are coming from long term care
and nursing home type facilities and
prisons which are big hot spots for
outbreaks of corona virus at one point
as I told you the florida state
government prevented stopped medical
examiners from releasing death totals
and also cause of death and both of
those things were being done therefore
for many many years that was standard
operating practice we reported on that
already and as usual we still don't have
transparency in terms of the full scope
of what they're hiding or potentially
falsifying we do need to get more of the
story from Rebecca Jones she hopefully
will be more communicative with
reporters in the upcoming period of time
now in terms of the numbers that Florida
has been releasing you know earlier in
the week I mentioned when you look at
some states that have been open versus
closed you see very similar curves and
we speculated this could be because an
open state might have a lot of people
isolating on their own whereas a closed
state might have a lot of people
ignoring the protocol it could be that
states are falsifying data we don't
really know in terms of the numbers that
Florida has released the case numbers
have been declining pretty modestly sort
of a similar pattern to states that have
been mostly shut down maybe a question
mark in light of this recent revelation
in terms of the deaths there's a strange
sort of herky-jerky up-and-down graph
for Florida deaths sometimes when you
see that it has to do with reporting
intervals where certain days of the week
you don't get full data and numbers are
pushed around potentially you know often
it's it's weekend
the numbers go down it's not because
fewer people they're dying on the
weekend it's because the reporting is
pushed to Monday and Tuesday and tallied
early in the following week we're not
really sure in terms of testing levels
Florida is testing about 33,000 per
million that puts them at 27th in the
United States that's right about the
middle Florida's not particularly good
or bad on testing but again this is what
they are releasing and that's all we
really know we may know more soon as I
say but we may not and that's the whole
point that this is a story about the
fact that we are not being given
information that is absolutely necessary
to figure out what's going on in Florida
to determine are they ready to move to a
phase one or phase two reopening or
whatever the case may be
once again it's projection that the
right has been saying that the left is
falsifying data for a while now no
actual evidence of that but now
increasingly evidence that it is the
right that may be indeed doing that and
the very right-wing Florida State
Government of Governor Ron de santis is
at the at the center of this at this
point in time hey this is really weird
speaking of cases Donald Trump now says
he is honored not horrified not
concerned Trump is honored that we in
the United States have by far the most
corona virus infections in the world
this is extremely odd here is the man
himself saying it so when we have a lot
of cases I don't look at that as a bad
thing I look at that as in a certain
respect as being a good thing because it
means our testing is much better so if
we were testing a million people instead
of 14 million people we would have far
few cases right so I view it as a badge
of honor this is absolutely crazy Trump
Trump talks about this as an honor he's
not really honoring the victims or their
families when he continues to just
flippantly remark about we've we've
passed the peak we figured it out we're
the best we've got the most has the best
test we've got all the equipment we've
got all the different stuff we're
reopening it's all
right we did so well he doesn't seem to
be honoring anyone and Trump continues
to be completely confused about testing
he keeps talking about raw numbers we've
you know a million tests 14 million
tests let's give this some serious
thought because this matters you know
Trump's wacky comment about a badge of
honor from having the most infections
it's not some is bonkers off the wall
cuckoo for cocoa puffs but let's use it
to actually get informed about things
let's not just dismiss it as the
rantings of a lunatic which it is but
Trump's idea is we have so many
infections because we have so much
testing okay let's explore that let's
look at the numbers of the five million
global confirmed coronavirus cases the
US has about 1.6 million so what we have
in the u.s. is 32 percent of the cases
but we only have 4% of the population so
the cases are out of sync with our
population now we have more cases than
the next I think it's six countries
combined globally the case numbers are
crazy but do we have the most cases
because we have the most testing well
not really in the sense that our testing
per capita is still only 38th in the
world
so what Donald Trump is claiming doesn't
make any sense and we still are only
testing about three hundred and
seventy-five thousand people per day I
sound like a broken record I've told you
many times now we should have been at
500 thousand a day more than a month ago
we need to get to five thousand and five
hundred thousand a day to eventually get
to one and a half to five million tests
per day that's what you need to really
be doing significant surveillance
testing where you would say listen
regardless of symptoms if you are 65 or
older you need to get it go and get a
test this week okay next week if you are
between 55 and 65 go and get a test you
need one and a half to five million
tests a day to be able to start doing
that kind of surveillance testing we are
nowhere close to that even still let's
move on to the next analysis maybe most
importantly there is no doubt that case
numbers do depend on testing even if the
u.s. is only three
per capita in testing but deaths do not
depend on testing and when you look at
deaths per capita the United States is
12th highest in the world in deaths per
capita out of more than 180 countries as
Donald Trump often likes to say our
deaths per capita not total deaths now
okay we're of course we're number one in
total deaths but that's that's different
we're talking about deaths per capita
deaths per capita the United States is
the 12th highest out of more than 180
countries so a lot of people have been
writing to me saying David you've got to
talk about this with Joe Rogan next time
you go on I do hope that this comes up
next time I go on and talk with Joe
Rogan about it I want to get the data
out there and and the the frustrating
thing about this is that it's shocking
how many people are making claims about
cases deaths testing without
understanding that you can just go find
the data very often I will tweet a
screenshot of testing numbers per capita
deaths you know whatever right I'll
tweet it and in the responses people are
responding to things where it's implicit
that we just don't have access to a
bunch of this data the data is available
and one of the things that you know if I
get an opportunity at some point soon to
talk with Joe Rogan about this it's not
going to be about attacking anyone or
proving anybody wrong it's going to be
to point out that we don't have to
speculate about a lot of this stuff
because we have the data now if you want
to argue there is something missing from
the data or the data is inaccurate in
some way I welcome that discussion it
seems increasingly when we look at
places like Florida that the
inaccuracies go in favor of those who
want to pretend that this is no big deal
but I welcome the opportunity to do that
okay we have a voicemail number the
number is two one nine two david p that
for people who aren't able to translate
that into numbers i want to mention that
the number is two one nine two three two
eight four three seven you can call it
any time of day here's a voicemail about
an issue that also I look for forward to
opportunities to clarify on other
programs and it is about whether the US
is the worst or not on our coronavirus
response table ISM we we
we have the worst record of anybody we
have one third of the deaths one third
of the cases of the whole planet there's
no doubt that we're the worst the world
there's absolutely no doubt okay so
here's where I am on this I I don't know
that the United States coronavirus
response has been the worst in the world
and I've been careful not to say that
it's been one of the worst and if you
say who had the worst responses slowest
most propagandistic suppressing data not
testing you know all this different
stuff from the countries we know of that
have had a bunch of cases the United
States is certainly on the list of the
worst Brazil is on the list of the worst
India seems to be on that list Russia is
on the list of the worst responses you
know I've heard anecdotally that
Turkmenistan had a terribly
propagandistic totalitarian response I
just don't know enough about that and
it's a very small country so you know it
could be difficult sometimes to glean
everything we want to Queen North Korea
is thrown around but here's where I
think we need to shift the conversation
on this instead of arguing is the u.s.
the worst or are we like fifth worst or
10th worst or 20th worst what happened
to American exceptionalism what happened
to the people who say and believe the US
should be the best at everything we
certainly were not the best and we
weren't second best or third best or
fourth best so let's shift the debate
from are we really the worst or just bad
- why are we now using that as a
standard since when is the standard in
the United States from those who
subscribe to the idea of American
exceptionalism since what is the
standard have we avoided being the worst
the standard has always been are we the
best and no one can argue that we are
the best merely looking at South Korea
Taiwan Japan Greece you know even a
bunch of European countries we're
certainly not in the top ten I would
argue we are in the worst ten and all of
a sudden the debate is are we are aren't
we the worst that was never the debate
if you
believe in American exceptionalism do
not let them hijack that conversation we
have a great bonus show for you today
producer Pat Forde will be joining me I
also want to remind you Monday Memorial
Day Monday Memorial Day we are doing a
one-day membership kablooie as I am
calling it membership kablooie to take
us back to the days of Warner Brothers
cartoons we will email everybody on our
mailing list on Monday with a one-day
coupon code which will give you an
absolutely disgusting discount off of
membership so if you've been thinking of
getting a membership and haven't yet
kind of waiting around for that
opportunity Monday Memorial Day is the
opportunity be notified on Monday by
signing up for our mailing list at david
pakman.com upper right of the website
you type in your email address I'm doing
my typing motion type in your email
address and then Monday you will get
that email with this just I mean it's
it's a vial coupon code quite frankly
you would be shocked when you see it
that does it for today on the bonus show
we will talk about UK citizens being
designated organ donors by default very
interesting story we will talk about
some gyms starting to reopen despite the
fact that they aren't supposed to yep I
will give you an update on my gym I
think we will hear from Pat about his
gym and we also now are getting an
apology
from Republican Georgia Governor Brian
Kemp because lo and behold it's not just
Florida the Georgia website incorrectly
showed a downward trend in coronavirus
infections which was not accurate all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show I'll see you then
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's sponsor
blue chew is giving you your first
shipment completely free all you have to
do is pay five dollars shipping go to
blue to calm and use the promo code
David I've put a link right underneath
this video